I am constantly surprised by the number
of cooking rules accepted cooking
concepts that can and should be broken
and and even in the time that I've been
making shows about food I've had to face
my own lack of imagination I used to be
a proponent of the old fill a big pot of
water and bring it to a boil to cook
your dry pasta and I accepted it because
I've been trained by people that beated
enemy and and then later if you question
these things you realize gee I can
actually cook dry pasta better in a very
small amount of cold water that's
brought to the boil or very often
searing a steak is best done after
you've done most of the cooking which is
not what his has been taught so I think
that when it comes to food innovation
and kind of day to day tips to get
better food on the table requires
constant questioning the word Y which
most of us didn't ask in food 20 years
ago is now the the most important word
that we can use why why do we do this
why we always seared steak before we
finished cooking the steak
why don't we roast it and then sear it
these are all questions that we have to
kind of constantly ask but you know that
the pasta water one is probably the most
simple one I can think of we have all
been taught to boil our pasta and
massive amounts of water and it
absolutely makes no sense whatsoever
when you think about it and when you
start asking the question why a lot of
figuring out how to handle your food is
based on trying to have a clear
understanding of the actual food what is
in that food and the heat that you are
applying and what you want to get done
let's say that you want a nice big juicy
steak that's medium-rare if it has a
really great sear on the outside now a
lot of people would say well fine we're
gonna take that out of the refrigerator
and we're gonna get a pan really hot or
a grill really hot we're gonna slap it
on there we're gonna turn it over and
we're gonna stick it with a fork a few
times and and then we're gonna call it
done but when you start really thinking
about what a steak is made up of the
system of mussels myofibrils and the
things that actually were
inside a muscle and the chemicals that
are involved you start to realize wow
what I really need to do is is think of
it as is three different thermal trips I
get it out of the refrigerator and let
it come to room temperature because that
is going to allow for faster cooking I
want a really good sear but I want most
of the interior the meat to be
medium-rare okay well in that case what
I really need to do is to make my
primary cooking method about what I want
most of the meat to be so what makes
sense I treat it like a roast I put it
in the oven at a lower temperature let
the the inside of the meat get closer to
that medium-rare temperature take it out
rest it for a little while
salt it and then sear the outside so if
you actually start thinking about it is
two different pieces of meat I'm cooking
the interior the meat and I'm cooking
the exterior than meat and there are
actually two different processes and
that sounds complicated but actually
it's not it does however require that
you understand something about what meat
actually is and how it actually works
cooking pasta
we've always brought huge amounts of
water to a boil and dumped it in why
have we done that well a lot of people
kind of argue about how we got into the
into the habit of doing that and it
would take a really long time to discuss
that but in examining it is a practice
say what is this make sense what are we
trying to do we're trying to rehydrate
something without overcooking it we're
trying to make it al dente that is we
want it to be a certain texture in the
tooth we don't want to be mushy we don't
want to be too done well by cooking it
in boiling water we still have to think
about the fact that we're saturating a
very dense dried piece of starch and
protein okay most dry pasta being made
with relatively high protein wheat
varieties so what do we really need to
do well we need to bring it to a boil
that's true because we've got some
certain expectations for the outside of
that noodle from a texture standpoint
but the wise thing is to actually start
it at least in my opinion is to start it
in colder water so that we're slowly
bringing it up to temperature which
gives more time for the the starches to
rehydrate without actually over cooking
and it's just a matter of kind of
thinking about what does this food
actually need from a realistic
standpoint what is it and how is heat
and water going to affect it when you
kind of
get down that way it leads you to some
hypotheses which hopefully lead you to
some experiments which hopefully lead
you to better food let's talk about pie
dough pie dough is the reason that most
people don't make pie because it's
almost impossible to teach how to do it
through a through a written recipe you
really do need to be able to do it next
to someone that and that's why we used
to be better bakers so we used to you
know learn from from our grandmothers
our parents being right there doing it
we don't anymore we we learn off of for
the interwebs and off of books but
here's the thing you've got to make
something wet in order to bring it
together to Adele but the problem is is
that water and the proteins in wheat
flour very often form this very very
elastic matrix that we call gluten now
there are a lot of ways to say well
we're just gonna use a gluten-free flour
and we start laying in all these other
fight and that's fine
but you could also just change the
nature of the liquid nobody said that
you should only use water and in fact
when I make pie dough I use vodka
instead of water because it's a liquid
but it's got a lot less actual water in
it and that water tends to stay bound to
the to the ethanol that is in the
alcohol rather than binding up as much
with the the weed proteins and we're not
talking about enough it's not like it's
a martini or anything but it'll actually
give you a better quality pie dough that
won't be gummy won't be as hard to work
with and it'll take a lot less liquid so
there's just another thing of thinking
of I need to know what my ingredients
are and how they act okay well water and
flour do this I don't want that what
else can I use vodka you've got some in
the freezer probably
you